of all the blank slates that star in
videogames lightning is one of the
blankest lightning returns final fantasy
xiii points out its own heroines lack of
emotion on many occasions but making
lightning stoicism a plot point doesn't
make it easier to relate to her she is
defined only by her love for her sister
Sarah and by how the god named
bhunivelze needs her to carry out his
will
lightning is a sister and a savior
defined not by her own traits but by the
needs of this role-playing games plot
and so I was chosen by God to rescue
lost souls and guide them past the end
of this world and
I became the savior the stage for this
plot are the four regions of Nova
Cresselia that you traverse over and
over again as you perform the tasks
required of you the world is soon to end
and lightning is the key to God's plan
for a new beginning lightning returns is
not a game about lightning however but
about the drama of its defining moments
as a theatrical expression of light
music and spectacular feats of magic the
game's cutscenes excel the musics wounds
fireworks fill the screen and for a
moment the pageantry sweeps you away
it's beginning
sadly the audio production is all too
often a major distraction hope s time is
your guide of sorts and he never shuts
up
he drones on so often in fact that he's
constantly cut off mid-sentence whenever
a battle suddenly occurs or when you
trigger a cutscene you might think you
could simply wait for dialogue to finish
before venturing forward and in theory
you can however lightning returns is
designed to make you hurry you see the
world is going to end whether you like
it or not and the clock is always
ticking the game adheres to a strict
timetable to see lightning returns to
its finale you need to add days to the
calendar by saving souls which in turn
means completing story quests stopping
to listen to entire lines of dialogue
uses up precious minutes
[Music]
in fact it's quite easy to not even
reach the end of the game the first time
you play if you play on medium
difficulty you see lightning returns
likes to waste your time and it does so
and how it handles exploration as you
complete certain side quests others may
open up but you may not know where and
when they do so the game invites you to
return to regions again and again
seeking out new activities and chasing
MacGuffins only to punish you with time
loss if there's nothing to be found
should the world end before you complete
your main quests you have to start over
but you do keep all of your equipment
and enhancements new game+ style
lightning returns also wastes your time
by forcing you to lose an in-game hour
whenever you escape from battle you
might be well equipped for the creatures
in the vicinity only to discover that
you're not powerful enough for the boss
that concludes your quest and be forced
to escape the combat system encourages
you to experiment but the time limit
punishes you for it you want to be saved
time you met you later
the combat does have its bright spots
however at the heart of battle are
combat templates called schemata
schemata in turn are attached to the
outfits lightening wears
she can wear up to three at any time and
switch between them at will during
battle not only the various outfits have
their own attributes but so do the
weapons attacks and accessories you can
equip to them there are countless ways
to fine tune your schemata and playing
around with the possibilities as
lightning returns most interesting and
most enjoyable element lightning
skitters across the battlefield as you
unleash various attacks each attack
costs a certain number of active Time
battle points and the ATB meter
replenishes more slowly than you use it
up as a result you must switch between
schemata frequently as well as block
effectively to stagger enemies and avoid
damage sadly that blocking mechanic is a
big problem to avoid the most damage you
need to be absolutely precise but when
the camera is swaying about it's rarely
giving you a consistent view of your
surroundings even in the alternate
camera view and you can't walk attacks
you can't see coming
you might suppose that grinding four
levels would boost your battle
effectiveness but lightning doesn't gain
levels and there's no experience
together instead completing quests
rewards you with additional health
additional strength or other perks you
still end up grinding but you're
grinding for the items monsters drop so
that you can turn them in for quest
rewards while backtracking across the
same sand dunes and winding paths grows
tiring
there are countless details to admire
lightening herself Don's meticulously
tailored outfits with every button
polished to a shine and each fabric
impeccably embroidered you can see how
much attention was given to the visual
details and it made me wish that more
attention had been given to creating
characters worth caring about and
structuring the game in a way that made
it enjoyable to explore I don't know
where Final Fantasy will go from here
but I hope that lightning returns is
simply another bump on the series path
and not a harbinger of more mediocrity
to come
is this fruit from a light
you